[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi à 21 janvier
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition
la visite des manuels macron à
l'université paris saclay le président
de la république est venu dévoiler le
plan de la france pour développer
l'ordinateur quantique 1,8 milliard
d'euros va être déboursés sur cinq ans
en ce sens en marge de ce déplacement le
chef d'état rencontré également des
étudiants les étudiants justement privés
de cours en présentiel depuis plusieurs
mois se sont rassemblés cette semaine
dans plusieurs villes de france pour
faire part de leur détresse et dans ce
journal le témoignage de deux jeunes qui
suivent leur cursus à distance
quel impact psychologique nous poserons
la question à la psychanalyste catherine
grand jard qui est notre invité et puis
l'épidémie a poussé aussi la cantine
scolaire à s'adapter depuis la semaine
dernière le protocole sanitaire déjà
strictes a été renforcée par de
nouvelles règles
exemple à voisins le bretonneux et à
plaisir aujourd'hui c'est ouvert
également un salon de l'étudiant un peu
particulier crise sanitaire oblige il se
déroule cette année en virtuel
avec l'investissement que nous décidons
aujourd'hui collectivement c'est à dire
un engagement public privé de 1,8
milliard d'euros
avec près d'un milliard d'euros venant
directement de l'état
ce que je suis venu vous dire cette
profonde et une profonde accélération et
transformation de notre écosystème
mais le fait aussi que nous décidons de
nous mettre sur le podium mondial en
termes de financement d'investissements
en termes de cantine le président de la
république emmanuel macron s'est donc
rendu ce jeudi sur l'université paris
saclay visite au centre des nanosciences
et des nanotechnologies de palaiseau il
a dévoilé la stratégie quantique
nationale une feuille de route à long
terme a été présenté aux industriels et
académiques pour préparer la france de
2030 au total 1,8 milliard d'euros va
être investi dans la recherche et le
développement de technologies quantiques
elle permettrait notamment est
d'augmenter les vitesses de calcul de
créer un ordinateur pour résoudre des
problèmes qui ne pourrait être résolu
avec les machines actuelles écoutez la
réaction de cet entrepreneur spécialisé
dans l'informatique quantique
interrogé par justine brasier elle
partie des 8 milliards il va au les
laboratoires pour des grands projets de
recherche fondamentale car il faut
continuer dans cette voie c'est très
important
faut pas penser que c'est terminé et
puis ensuite il ya des grands projets de
d'applications donc commencé à mettre en
route deux réseaux de communication
quantique 1 entre paris et à paris
saclay il ya dans la région de nice par
exemple ça c'est du concret c'est sur le
terrain et ensuite au niveau des
ordinateurs quantiques il y a comme
ambition d'avoir un ordinateur quantique
français britt et en 2023 il concernant
cette thématique dans les yvelines
atos va inaugurer son laboratoire
quantique aux clayes-sous-bois est ce
cette année en 2021
en marge de ce déplacement emmanuel
macron a également rencontré des
étudiants sur le campus de l'université
paris saclay avec la crise sanitaire
leur quotidien a été chamboulé peu ou
pas de cours en présentiel pas de petits
boulots crainte d'une insertion
professionnelle plus difficile cette
semaine d'ailleurs des centaines
d'étudiants s'étaient rassemblés dans
plusieurs villes de france pour
manifester leur détresse astrid bergère
et eléonore sinoquet sont allés
justement à la rencontre de deux
étudiants et blinois regarder vadimir
est étudiant en master 2 à paris
dauphine une image n'est pas finir ses
études dans de telles conditions
ce changement radical avec le début de
son cursus a été difficile à vivre dans
la fois que j'étais en cours c'était le
22 octobre
on était sur un système
semi-présidentiel ce midi ce temps ciel
dès septembre donc j'ai pu me préparer
un peu tout ça mais les débuts quand on
est passé en 10 anciennes total ça a été
assez compliqué parce qu'on perd le le
contact avec les autres
on perd le contact aussi avec les
enseignants et sur une année comme celle
du masters de ces cas là c'est compliqué
parce que c'est une année où on a besoin
de beaucoup de soutien
j'ai vu des passages à vide
j'en ai vu un aussi d'ailleurs ça fait
un mois et demi on était au coeur du
confinement en fait et c'est vrai que là
la solitude commençait à se sentir si
aujourd'hui son moral va mieux c'est en
partie grâce à l'un des responsables de
son master qui lui a donné des conseils
pour mieux s'organiser au quotidien mais
ce manque de lien avec les autres
camarades se ressent aussi sur le
travail
j'ai senti que ça joue sur la cohésion
de la promotion parce qu'en fait
finalement je connais moins comme on se
connaît moins on sait moins forcément
comment les autres fonctionnent et ça
peut créer des tensions notamment dans
les travaux de groupe pour lui qui est
en fin d'études
l'insertion dans le monde du travail est
une grande source d'inquiétude pour
valider les masters on doit aussi avoir
un stage est là en ce moment pour voir
des stages c'est compliqué les
entreprises nous disent qu'elles
prennent pas des stagiaires à cause du
coc vide on sait pas non plus quels
seront les débouchés sur l'emploi après
donc c'est c'est très compliqué louis
étudiant en première année de cinéma vit
dans un campus
il a donc davantage de proximité avec
d'autres jeunes de son âge
je suis un petit appartement mais ça
fait au final comme s'ils s'étaient
plaints d'appartements dans un grand
immeuble on se fait rapidement des potes
on sort un peu le soir
bon en limitant collier dame nature mais
non son
entre on travaille ensemble et puis
enfin franchement c'est bon c'est bon
enfant et c'est cool
malgré cette proximité il était loin de
s'imaginer un tel début de vie étudiante
alors mes études avant j'ai imaginé
vraiment mode faire la fête tout le
temps et j'ai imaginé vraiment c'était
c'était ça et c'est ce qui me plaisait
aussi dans les études c'est cette part
deuxièmement c'est hyper festif sont
taillés en armes à la majorité on va
faire plein de trucs moi on va vraiment
vivre nos années nous années 20 à quoi
bon c'est très limité du coup les
psychologues observe une hausse de
nouveaux patients chez les étudiants
louis n'en fait pas partie mais pour
certains de ses amis de la situation est
différente
alors non je vais pas voir de 2-1 après
j'en parle beaucoup avec les admins sur
tous mes amis qui sont sur la côte vers
ronnement tout ça c'est sûr que c'est un
sujet car ce qui revient assez souvent
surtout j'ai des copains en paces et
pour eux c'est l'horreur et franchement
je me compare à eux et je me dis je suis
vraiment dans une bonne situation
face aux difficultés que rencontrent les
étudiants emmanuel macron a annoncé de
nouvelles mesures
il souhaite le retour des étudiants au
moins une journée en présentiel par
semaine et il affirme que les boursiers
et non boursiers pourront désormais
manger deux fois par jour au restaurant
universitaire pour un euro le président
de la république a d'ailleurs annoncé
confirmé aujourd'hui la création d'un
chèque psy à destination des étudiants
qui le souhaitent il permettra à partir
du 1er février est de pouvoir consulter
un psychologue ou un psychiatre et de
suivre des soins
justement on parle de cet impact de la
crise sanitaire qui peut avoir cet
impact sur sur les étudiants avec mon
invité par visioconférence et catherine
grand jard bonsoir oui vous êtes
psychanalystes psychologues et
psychosociologue installées à ben alors
déjà une réaction à cette annonce la
mise en place d'un chèque psychologique
pour les étudiants annoncé par emmanuel
macron est ce que c'est une bonne chose
selon vous du coup ça ne permet ça
permet de ne pas mettre cette thématique
celle de l'impact psychologique dès que
peut avoir la crise sanitaire sur les
étudiants de côté bien sûr c'est une
excellente chose puisqu'on sait que le
nombre
deux professionnels psychologues à
disposition des étudiants dans les
centres c'est vraiment ridicule
donc il faut faciliter économiquement
parlant avec l'échec la possibilité de
consulter puisqu'on sait aussi que cette
période est extrêmement difficile
elle l'est pour tout le monde elle est
en particulier pour les étudiants qui
parfois se retrouvent seuls et dans le
reportage on a bien vu la différence
entre celui qui vit en campus et celui
qui vit seul isolé il y à aussi tous ces
gens qui vivent mal accompagné dans des
groupes où ça se passe pas bien
camille voir en couple
et tout ceci complique les situations
qui ne sont pas nés du confinement ou du
couvre-feu mais sont aggravées par ses
conditions de vie est ce que justement
ce moment vous avez beaucoup de
sollicitations pour des consultations de
l'apport de d'étudiants ou même de
jeunes en général qui peuvent être
impactés par cette crise sanitaire
ah oui je prends confiance que vous
dites
il y à beaucoup plus de demandes de
consultations en général et en
particulier donc là pour la population
jeune étudiante lycéenne qui s'inquiète
toutes ces incertitudes pour l'avenir
c'est difficile à gérer pour des gens
encore mal insérés dans la vie et donc
le passage aux études supérieures est
quelque chose qui déstabilisent par
définition puisque on quitte un monde et
on va dans un autre c'est une transition
est donc là c'est cette année est
particulièrement compliqué et on ne sait
pas quand ça va s'arrêter
est-ce que les heures sombres sont
encore devant nous il se peut on n'a pas
de boule de cristal
personne ne peut le dire et donc ce sont
les ressources internes qui compte pour
sécuriser les gens et ses ressources
internes elles sont
construire à développer à faire grandir
dans cette situation de crise sanitaire
le sentiment qui règne au travers de vos
consultations avec vos passions c'est
quoi c'est le sentiment de détresse
d'abandon également en ce qui concerne
le cas des étudiants
qu'est-ce qui décrit très très très
variable il y as détresse il y as
abandon il y a un sentiment d'être sans
avenir sans vision de l'avenir plus
exactement
rien ne se passe comme prévu il faut
s'adapter
il y a beaucoup de gens qui se sentent
perdus et c'est peut-être ce mot perdu
avec des degrés à la détresse et
l'abandon c'est le degré maximal mais il
y a une sorte de mal être est évidemment
de solitude d'isolement le fait de ne
pas aller en cours de ne pas nouer des
relations sociales les relations de
travail pas pour les ainsi faire la fête
et pour les choses c'est avoir des
contacts pouvoir travailler à plusieurs
voiliers tout ceci fait partie de la
jeunesse c'est dur à tous les âges mais
c'est peut-être particulièrement dur
quand on démarre dans la vigne et ses
mots ses mots et mali x sont tellement
répondu que ça devient d'une banalité
affligeante dec mal dans sa peau
justement être privé de ses interactions
sociales à ce moment de la vie vous
parlez d'un moment important c'est un
moment finalement quand on est étudiant
on s'émancipe davantage on devient un
jeune adulte est ce que ça peut avoir de
graves répercussions pour pour la suite
merci c'est un moment de construction
c'est un moment de transition
c'est un moment d'émancipation donc bien
évidemment ces privations de liberté ça
crée une frustration absolument énorme
on s'était imaginé la vie autrement on
pensait on fantasmait depuis longtemps
ce passage comme étant vraiment très
intéressant
là rien ne se passe comme prévu patatras
il faut il faut rebondir et donc moi
vraiment je vais insister pour tout le
monde
ah parce que tout le monde n'y a pas en
consultation mamane bien pour tout le
monde ce sont les ressources internes
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand ça se passe
pas comme prévu vers quoi on va pouvoir
se diriger en se disant bon il faut
quand même que j'en tire quelque chose
de positif hier archi zh et peut-être
les les points importants de l'existence
les appuis et puis si besoin se dire bon
là ça va absolument pas du tout qu'est
ce que je vais changer parce que
peut-être c'est un mode de vie qui doit
être changé si on est seul et qu'on
supporte pas la solitude
il faut aller vivre en coloc si on est
au colloque ont famille et que ça se
passe mal il faut peut-être tenter
quelque chose donc vous voyez c'est tout
ça que cet épisode doit pouvoir faire
réfléchir pour ce pour ne pas perdre son
temps parce que sinon il ya ce sentiment
atroce que les jours passent sans piles
et on n'en fait rien du tout dernière
station catherine granger en 30 secondes
très rapidement est ce que vous vous
êtes inquiète vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure c'est une crise dont on ne
connaît pas la fin est ce que vous êtes
de nature inquiète avec peut-être des
des répercussions psychologiques qui
ressortiront dans plusieurs mois dans
plusieurs années peut-être c'est pas que
je sois de nature inquiète mais c'est
que je sais qu'il y a des répercussions
qui peuvent se profiler dans plusieurs
mois
parfois on tient durant l'épreuve on
s'écroule à peine après dont le voyez en
quelques mots c'est les heures sombres
doivent aller renforcer ce qui est au
fond de nous ce qu'on trouve pas à
l'extérieur bien on fait vraiment
s'épanouir
ce que l'on porte et on y est rare
cheese c'est ça peut-être mes conseils
merci avec catherine granger justement
pour ses conseils rappelle que vous êtes
psychanalystes psychologues et
psychosociologue et vous êtes installés
à ben dans les yvelines
merci d'avoir été avec nous comme soit
merci face à l'impossibilité justement
de se réunir en présentiel la majorité
des salons d'orientation a été rendu
virtuel cette année c'est le cas du
salon de l'étudiant en ile-de-france qui
s'est ouvert ce jeudi c'est jusqu'à
samedi un événement qui sera accessible
en replay et ce jusqu'au 21 février les
précisions de bixente mais rien senti
steban nous avions l'habitude de les
voir se rassembler pour discuter avec
les professeurs et autres intervenants
en vue de leur orientation future
les étudiants auront cette année accès à
des salons virtuels développé pour les
accompagner le mieux possible
quand on se connecte on arrive dans un
rôle différent qui passe avec différents
lieux des changes
et puis on a construit de façon à ce
qu'on puisse malgré tout mettre en place
ce qui importe où n en fait c'est d
interaction directe avec les différents
intervenants parmi les principaux enjeux
cette année parcours sup plusieurs de
neuf conférences organisées par le média
l'étudiant sont dédiés à la plateforme
d'orientation post bac
c'est vraiment l'occasion pour ces
jeunes qui se posent des questions sur
cette procédure et l'on sait à quel
point ça peut être compliqué en cette
période de crise sanitaire et à quel
point déjà d'ordinaire ça peut être un
petit peu anxiogène
les conférences seront accessibles en
replay jusqu'au 21 février afin que
chacun puisse prendre le temps de se
renseigner un nouveau format qui
pourrait être utilisé en complément du
salon physique dès l'année prochaine ou
dans le reste de l'actualité les
transports en ile-de-france qui s'adapte
au couvre-feu ce matin la présidente de
la région valérie pécresse a annoncé que
l'offre sur le réseau allait être
renforcée entre 15h et 18h
l'objectif permettre aux franciliens de
rentrer en temps et en heure chez eux
pour le couvre-feu rang s'offre
renforcement qui devrait intervenir dans
les prochains jours la région d'y
travailler sur le sujet avec les
associations d'usagers et ligne par
ligne
adaptation également des cantines
scolaires pendant cette crise sanitaire
depuis la rentrée elles sont soumises à
un protocole strict protocole qui a été
renforcé la semaine dernière après les
dernières annonces gouvernementales
reportage à voisins le bretonneux et
plaisir de célia gars de son go et
nicolas dandois la cantine de l'école du
bois de la garenne à voisins le
bretonneux respecte depuis le mois de
juin un protocole strict pour protéger
les enfants de lakovic avec un sens de
circulation pour éviter le brassage et
le croisement des groupes d'enfants
il y à un animateur par classe qui est
chargé de gérer le passage aux
sanitaires le lavage des mains nous
avons également la mise en place sur les
services les animateurs servent le pain
individuellement ils servent de l'eau
les enfants ne circulent plus au sein du
réfectoire un plan de table a été établi
par classes et les élèves doit rester
sur la même table toute la semaine de
service sont effectués pour ne pas
mélanger les élèves nous n'avons jamais
changé
le protocole sanitaire depuis le mois de
juin
alors qu'on aurait pu le relâcher en
septembre mais on est resté toujours sur
la même chose donc on était en avance
sur ce qui nous était demandé
dans cet autre école élémentaire à
plaisir les élèves doivent porter le
masque en permanence et sont eux aussi
rangé par classe on doit absolument
se mettre avec sac laisse donc si tu as
d'autres copains dans une autre classe
va tu peux pas aller manger avec eux
donc c'est dommage mais si tu as des
combats dans ta classe balle c'est bien
faut pas que tu touches à tour avec
voilà virus c'est normal c'est pour
faire c'est pour le bien des autres
la cantine fonctionne en self une
réorganisation a dû être également fait
un animateur dédié avec des gants et un
lavage de main préalable pour servir au
plateau le pain les couverts et ensuite
les enfants passent sur le self dans
certaines cantines des écoles de la
ville la mairie a instauré trois
services objectif moins d'enfants dans
le réfectoire voisins le bretonneux où
nous étions dans ce reportage le collège
champollion à adapter l'accès à sa
cantine en limitant le nombre d'élèves
pour se plier au renforcement du
protocole les places en demi pension
sont résorbés sont réservés désormais
aux collégiens en situation de handicap
aux boursiers aux 6e et à deux classes
de 5e les autres élèves peuvent accéder
à des paniers repas joint par notre
rédaction ni l'établissement ni
l'académie de versailles n'ont souhaité
s'exprimer sur le sujet cette image à
poissy à présent le journaliste sportif
pierre ménès c'était ce jeudi au centre
de vaccination chez maurice est le maire
de la commune karl olive l'a accueilli à
cette occasion pierre ménès fait partie
des personnes à risque puisqu'il a subi
deux greffes rhin et fois ces dernières
années il a donc décidé de recevoir la
première injection dès aujourd'hui avant
un rappel dans quinze jours on écoute sa
réaction au micro de michael et demi
d'euros et de marilou le gall jaffe le
pragmatique dans la vie on a pleuré pour
avoir des masques quand il y avait des
matches on voulait pas en mettre on a
pleuré pour avoir des vaccins
aujourd'hui
voit que quasiment la moitié des
français un petit peu moins heureusement
aujourd'hui qui sont contre moi je
trouve que voilà si on veut revivre
normalement qu'on veut que le pays
reparte normalement il faut qu'on soit
un maximum est
vacciner le plus vite possible je crois
à la force de l'image je crois à la
force de l'exemplarité et toutes celles
et ceux qui modestement peuvent inciter
encore une population qui est indécise à
se faire vacciner
elles en sont convaincus elles
deviennent convaincante avant de vous
laisser cet événement demain vendredi a
lu vs cussac rejoindre à l'espace à
partir de 15h 24 heures françaises
le nano satellites sera mise en orbite
par la fusée falcon 9 de space x
lancement depuis la base de cap
canaveral en floride est gros comme un
rubik's cube lui excuse ça n'a été
développé dans les locaux du latmos à
guyancourt ce satellite sera dédiée à
l'étude du bilan radiatif de la terre et
à l' influence de l'éclairement solaires
sur le climat un lancement que vous
pourrez suivre en direct demain sur tv
60,18 l'émission 7,8 week-end se
mobilisent pour l'occasion prise antenne
aux alentours de 15 heures 23 demain
vendredi
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité très belle soirée avec
tv 78
[Musique]